hello everybody how's everybody doing
Merry Christmas for those who celebrate
it you know I come from an atheist
background
my family was militant you know they
were militant atheists and we always
celebrated Christmas and Easter not for
religious reasons for sure hell we just
uh you know end of the year kind of
stuff celebrations nothing wrong with
that as far as I'm concerned at least we
still do celebrate my family anyways
Merry Christmas and for those of you who
won't see me next time Happy New Year as
well
I want to recap a little bit of the main
points that I've been trying to make the
extinction series okay and here to go
see if we can get it up there here and
these are the main points we have what I
call extinction 101 and that means that
you must first explain in an extinction
Theory how actual extinctions occurred
in other words we had animals in the
past not only the dinosaurs which are
the most famous but we had synapses we
had beings we had our co-stars
we had all kinds of animals in the past
and they're no longer around we see the
bones in the rock you measure the rock
you get an idea how old that layer is
and you get an idea of when those
animals were around and there's been all
these layers throughout our history
history of life on Earth and we had all
these animals there they're no longer
around and they weren't different types
of animals by doing bone analysis you
can tell okay they were quite different
and so you need to explain how they
disappeared first before you can talk
about the extinction of man why because
I'm saying and that man is is an animal
he belongs to the animal kingdom okay
just as simple as that and so
as a general rule of thumb it'd be nice
if we know how the animals in the past
died whatever it was and see if we can
escape whatever mechanism you know claim
their lives so if we cannot escape it
with our intelligence with our
technology with our foresight and all
the other good things that Mother Nature
gave us then we're gonna die in the same
way that's why we need to do extinction
101 first yeah people like to jump skip
and go through it meet the man they had
their experts in man well one fella did
criticize some things we got regarding
extinction 101 so I'm gonna be
addressing his comments today
okay address some of those the other day
as well some of his comments because
he's the only one really that is trying
to at least address the issue okay
whether right or wrong I'm saying that
all these animals died because their
food chain disappeared what we have is a
chronological disappearance of animals
in other words what specifically of food
chains it is the old food chain that
disappeared in a new one took over
that's what a mass extinction is it
claims a food chain and unfortunately
none of the paleontologists have ever
discovered that so I don't know about
their level of education or their level
of intelligence if they haven't figured
that out in 200 years that we've had
paleontology so I didn't consider any of
them paleontologist a paleontologist is
not a guy who goes out in the field
collects bones gives them a fancy name
and assembles them in a museum
that's a stamp collector that's not
paleontologists scientologists is a
forensic investigator you have to figure
out what the crime was how the animal
died he's a common that crawler just he
studies death that that's what they do
okay they study death they have to tell
us that's the job of a paleontologist to
tell you how the animals died yeah hello
anyways uh I say that animal was in the
past the primary mechanism was
starvation and that's the cookie cutter
no species can eventually given enough
time escaped starvation why because what
disappears are the plants underneath our
feet the plants that fed the herbivores
on which the carnivores depended and of
course the carnivores depend on other
carnivores as well right but that whole
pyramid disappears why because the
bottom level disappears what this
appears is the other plants that the
herbivores ate and I thought the
ecological pyramid overturn the pyramid
overturned you have the many carnivals
chasing after the fuel and viewer pet
herbivores which chase after fewer and
fewer plants that's essentially the
mechanism it's the overturning of the
ecological pyramid you have the trophic
levels invert okay so in starvation
explain cell activity especially
explains why a food chain disappears and
another one doesn't another one
continues most famous case the dinosaurs
disappeared they ate conifers we can
belong we were eating and just friends
and so we didn't even notice their
disappearance almost I mean they were
gone and we said oh we have freedom now
free at last
you know started radiating and that's
that's chronological extinction no doubt
famine can also be applied to any
habitat or climate okay
plants undergo cycles people are not
aware of that people think that plants
live forever they don't not species even
orders in higher levels you know don't
last forever what happens to them they
they lose their genetic diversity and
their population pyramid also overturns
when
and if but when it overturns the atom
was the herbivores that depended on that
source of food go with it they can't
change that the last moment and say well
instead of you know like a rabbit eats
lettuce maybe carrots Bugs Bunny right
he can at the last moment change the
switch over to pine leaves guy doesn't
happen and so that animal dies when
lettuce in the carrots disappear and
that's exactly the mechanism I explained
and I'm saying man cannot avoid that
same exact cookie cutter that same exact
process those causes when plants
disappear man disappears and you said
well why blow plants disappear we grow
them every day well they're not a
special case we grow them for money so
we have this abstraction we called trade
we have commerce we give money
essentially you might give some other
good but in general its money we
transfer money to someone and if someone
gives value to that money for him that's
important because he can do something
with it later and so he gives you food
for it and the question is whether that
the day that that flow of money stops
right whether anyone has any incentive
to produce and distribute food to the
cities to you okay and I'm saying the
global economy cannot exist forever
cannot continue to grow forever at some
point it collapses it crashes what I
mean by that is money is no more people
but no longer believe in money people no
longer accept money we have tons of
unemployment at that point in time there
are several factors that occur I'm not
going to go into detail with that right
now and the issue is that once that
happens nobody has any incentive to
produce the plant food to plant seeds or
whatever grow food or distribute it to
the safe and billions die in a matter of
weeks so I think this we die the same
way
animals died when our food sources
disappear what is interesting is that no
one has come up with a theory involving
food starvation we have all kinds of
theories out there except that one
nobody nobody's thinking about that that
humans can die because of food okay
everybody's thinking of asteroids and
the disease and climate change and other
nonsense that has nothing to do at all
with extinction but that's what people
believe that's what's in the news
anyways uh what we have here is also the
issue of whether humans are part of the
animal kingdom that was that's an issue
that's an issue because all these folks
they say look humans are animals but
they're not we're not animals
so are we animals or are we not animals
and so we have to use the word animal
consistently okay and this is the
classification that we find at least in
the Wikipedia I think just about I think
all biologists will agree with this just
about every individual out there most
mostly agrees with us we belong to the
animal kingdom whether you like it or
not you're an animal you know you have
hopefully that blood running through
your veins you breathe you you know you
sleep you eat right we belong to the
special or you know subcategory we'll
just calm subcategory we don't need to
know these in any scientific way these
are subcategories we're part of the
mammals were part of the hominids and
we're within that part of the hominids
okay so that's our classification anyone
who wants to challenge that should take
it up with with the biologists I'm not
going to talk about that I think we are
animals we belong to the animal kingdom
and he who doesn't like it can go to
another planet and you know become a
plant or a rock or whatever well because
of that you know we suffer the same type
of problems that animals suffer and this
is one of them and that is that just
like it could with other animals in the
past our population is it will decline
eventually we will reach zero population
growth
it's right now it's predicted to happen
around mid-century this century the 21st
century so Ron mid-century we're going
to reach the zero population if
everything continues as it is going
right now I believe we're gonna reach
that point much sooner than mid-century
few years before that but that's my take
on that and why because we're producing
fewer babies there is no chance of
producing babies today because people
have moved from the country to the
cities okay and because of that
transition that's still going out there
even in poor countries
you know everybody's moving to the
cities the land is being bought out by
the big agricultural corporations and
they plant food and distribute it to the
cities where people are living so that's
what's that's the transition that's
going on right now and what I'm saying
is this graph tells us a lot and it
tells us something about this next graph
which is the population curve for any
species okay I'm saying all species
follow this curve whether they like it
or not including so-called non animal
man non animal humans we start out a
long time ago with a very sharp new
population pyramid bursar high solar
deaths then we after a long long long
long period we reach finally a you know
we're in this nomadic phase we
eventually reach region where we don't
colonize anymore you know humans are no
longer colonizing the earth and what
happens at that point we become
sedentary and at that point births
exceed deaths primarily because we get
used to the endemic diseases in the
region and si only for men that's for
any any animal once they migrate and
they stay in a region for a long time
they finally over the hundreds of years
of decades they finally get used to the
many of the diseases that afflicted
their parents their their ancestors and
what happens at that point the births
now
go work in general at least for humans
it does deaths go down because you know
we finding concrete disease in some way
in our case we also made our living
conditions much better etc and someone
can introduce vaccines also for those
who believe in vaccines as well you know
then at some point you know the
population pyramid starts overturning
because the births go down and the
deaths goes up and the reason for this
also is you know you you like I give the
example you can put a little piece of
bread on your table and leave it there
for a week or whatever and you'll see
that it turns green and the bacteria you
know they multiply on that piece of
bread but at some point their population
pyramid overturns they stop reproducing
exponentially and that's what's
happening demand and right now yeah the
births are going down the deaths are
going to go up they're gonna cross the
cribs are gonna cross and at some point
the purse are really gonna go down
nobody's gonna produce children and all
the old folks are gonna die and that's
when the population pyramid overturns
and so we are undergoing this process as
we speak you may be there where I show
it on the graph you may be right at that
point and so you know it's up to you to
figure out if that applies to you at all
okay
okay so that's in the summary okay let
me get back in here that's summary so
let me address some of the comments that
this fella primarily him I've got a
couple more comments in there but I'm
gonna trust primarily is because he at
least took the trouble and if you know
he has an opinion he has an idea he has
a theory and he writes then I usually
try to address these issues if I think
they're relevant and the reason I think
it's relevant in his case is that I
think you represents more or less how
ninety to ninety nine percent of the
people out there believe or think at
least most of the things that he said
son you may not agree with but I think a
lot of people will agree with a lot of
what this guy says and I disagree with
almost everything so
that means what I'm gonna say now yeah
you're gonna disagree with almost
everything I say and I'm already used to
that okay so here goes this fella first
I want to address the fact that he came
up with a case the other day about rats
in a little island and we were
discussing how they died and he thought
it was disease and so I made a
counter-argument that you know maybe
there are other causes out there that
killed the rats whatever you know or
that caused their extinction and I like
what he said made me laugh because he
says bill had an issue with the
extinction of the Christmas Island rat
and proposed hybridization I didn't
propose it in fact I specifically say
that I do not propose it and he's not
listening but okay but I like the next
stuff he says if we assume that both
theories have a 50% chance of being
correct and 50% of the less became
extinct by evolving into a different
species hybridization and 50% became
extinct through disease I loved it
because you know he's talking about 50%
extinction
you know I guess mother nature gives a
discount sometimes to some species and
so look we're only gonna extinct to you
50% terms called in anger but our sales
you know you get a take advantage of
that sales you know what is it Black
Friday or whatever so 50% become extinct
the other 50% though okay but let's
continue he says the following he says
you claim that we cannot avoid the same
mechanism of extinctions of dinosaurs
exactly man will become extinct extinct
yeah because of famine due to economic
collapse yeah that's what I'm saying
he got that part right I think okay the
real mechanism of extinction is not the
famine but the thing that led to the
famine
yeah I agree but to some degree in other
words we're talking about cause versus
mechanism those are two different things
okay
and I don't think he got had it right
there okay what was the economic
extinction for the dinosaurs well it
could be an Astra G illogical UPenn
disease etc
and you know again this guy's apparently
not listening I don't know how many
other people are in the same bone
they're not listening either but you
know I made it clear that you know here
are the possible scenarios for the
extinction of man that people propose I
show this the other day and you know the
the follow essentially the biblical
version you know you have the pestilence
your war in your conquest and you know
the biblical guys they cannot figure out
stuff like at astrophys they didn't they
didn't really think what happened what
happened in the past they didn't even
know there were dinosaurs or anything
like that even though they came up with
one catastrophe which was the forty days
and forty nights at God rained down on
us right but we invented catastrophes
essentially and that's very popular
these days
that's the NASA is pushing a lot of
those catastrophes extraterrestrial ones
because it's in their best interest and
you know we've got this climate change
habit that threats and population
explosions right but consume biggest me
the one that I'm proposing famine is
missing the the black horse is missing
from theories today okay and so yeah
that I'm saying that what triggered the
the mechanism is the lack of food that
would trigger it I did say what
triggered it see he kisses me says he
says the following he says reversal of
the food pyramid is the last step of the
mechanism of Bill's extinction model
yeah okay the cause of that reversal is
the real mechanism which bill has not
provided an answer for I did and he
wasn't listening he wasn't listening I
did say that plants disappear plants
disappear why because their population
pyramid overturns after millions of
years the conifers gave way to the
angiosperms you had and the conifers you
know officially you know you had all
these gymnosperms like the cycads cycad
likes and william Sonja's and they had
all
plants in those days those plants
disappeared most of those plants that
disappear we still have some conifers
today but the ones that the animals were
eating you know those disappeared and
they were there there
the forests were slowly disappearing as
angiosperms encroached on these forests
and today we have conifers on the planet
but they're not the rulers neither are
the ferns that preceded the conifers
well we have today's angiosperms people
don't realize this we don't eat conifers
we don't need ferns we eat what mammal
mammals in general you know all ten all
mammals we don't need conifers and then
in ferns which were the foods of
previous generations of animals what we
eat today all in all mammals including
us right for those who still believe
that we belong to the a Wild Kingdom
right
what whispers okay all our plant [ __ ]
the grasses you know all this stuff like
wheat already all that stuff that's
that's grasses so so yeah I did provide
a cause and the cause was the lack of
the fact that the plants suffer an
overturning of their population period
period meaning they also lost in the
process they lost their genetic
diversity okay so this is part of the
process okay so he put another comment
and he said proposes we have nothing
left to invent exactly I'm saying even
worse I'm saying we haven't had an
invention since about the 1980s there's
been no new invention he said Bill
you're crazy we had all kinds of
investors know what we've done an
invention is is something like a
telephone an invention something like a
car or an airplane we already invented
those if we invented TV but in the 1920s
the 40s we developed the TV and when you
look at a device like like a cell phone
it's just an agglomeration of all those
inventions what they did is put all
these inventions together in a handheld
carry-on that's what we always wanted we
wanted to be able to communicate
you know to a telephone see the person
television you know or watch a movie or
whatever use it as a computer we got it
now we've got it but what was that an
invention was the cell phone an
invention no the phone exists that the
computer exists that the television
exists that the radio investigate
existed all these were already out there
okay so I'm saying we have had no new
inventions in fact if you look at the
list of inventions that are being
registered which has ballooned by the
way you know we have more inventions
being registered at the Patent Office
but if you look at them they're all
cosmetic they're like you know instead
of one word what is it the type of beer
and they call that an invention now it's
not an invention those are things that
make people money yeah but that doesn't
mean it's an invention in the sense of
inventing something new that's not new
that's Peters beer is Peter's beard one
is a little more bitter another one it's
less bitter that's all there is maybe a
different color or whatever beers beers
beers beer and so that's not an
invention to say I invented a different
kind of beer No
so I don't consider those inventions the
fact that you made your car red instead
of blue does not change the fact that
that it's still a car that's my point
okay
computers been around I think that was
the last real invention and after that
there's been no invention but anyways
that's my take on that the arrogance of
that statement is mind-blowing I propose
we are only at the start of the journey
to unraveling nature's mysteries we have
no idea about consciousness space time
etc oh my god this is yeah I mean for a
guy who is awed by today's technology
and too swamped with information all
this is just mind-boggling yeah we have
no idea about conscious etc okay there
is so much we still don't know that we
have incentive to keep going for at
least another few millennia oh my god
another person put a comment there
robots will fill the needs people have
this idea that robots are going to run
the world or
invent ourselves out of some out of the
out of our out of our body is
essentially because what we're going to
be doing them we're going to then robots
robots are gonna be doing everything for
us we have this society that some people
are thinking or imagining and here are
some of the people who are doing that
okay
I'm sorry wrong one as always they get
something wrong it's this one here these
are the futurists okay and and these
these people proposed again that we're
going to look forever essentially or
they they don't talk about extinction
one was Carl Sagan guy I used to follow
a very strong because I I like the guy a
lot you know today I I just can't even
take up a seriously anymore
also his died for me and you got these
other guys Ray Kurzweil and Nick Bostrom
michio kaku
Neil Tyson and Brian Greene all these
people talk about future and they have
this idea of most of them do and I don't
know if all them subscribe to this but I
think most of them do either in secret
or in public okay and the technological
singularity the point at which
technology starts growing exponentially
primarily because we have the robots
doing the thinking for us we have these
Android side boys computers and all this
stuff will develop technology to greater
to unimaginable levels that we cannot
even imagine today okay that's that's
their notion okay and here's a Chris
whilst take on and he's what are the
guys that that is obviously proposing
this a day and he says the following
he says the singularity occurs as
artificial intelligence says surpass
human beings as the smartest and most
capable life-forms on the earth
technological development is taken over
by the machines who can think act and
communicate so quickly that normal
humans cannot
and comprehend what is going on the
machines entered into a runaway reaction
of self-improvement cycles with each new
generation of a eyes appeared faster and
faster from this point onwards
technological advancement is explosive
and cannot be accurately predicted what
a world huh but this is what these
people believe they believe that somehow
I mean as far as I'm concerned we
haven't had an invention the last 40
years and these people talk about the
technological singularity where we're
gonna fence so many things they're just
going to know that's just unimaginable
and the first problem I've got with that
is that even assuming that's true
manufacturing is dying the manufacture
is becoming a smaller and smaller
percentage not only of GDP but of labor
and so what are the same we're going
back to manufacturing manufacturing is
going to become eighty-five to ninety
percent of our economy again sometime in
the future we're all going to go back to
blue collars is that what these people
are saying that we're gonna invent
something that's gonna put billions of
people to work because it's just gonna
be so breathtaking or maybe it's just
that the robots don't work and we just
stay at home and and do what you know
what are we gonna do how we gonna get
our money if we don't work if the robots
do everything so you know they don't
look at that they look at this ideal
society where you're in your couch couch
potato you're watching TV or whatever I
don't even know if TVs are gonna be
around by that time you know but you
know watch television all day long doing
all this leisure stuff traveling around
the world and who's gonna pay for all
that I mean and even worse how do we get
to that point which is the big problem
really I mean I want to know how we get
to ten percent unemployment to 20
percent unemployment the 30 percent
unemployment to 40 percent unemployment
we can all imagine 100 percent
unemployment society even though that's
impossible to you know but assuming we
could imagine the 100 percent
unemployment society where
let's do everything how do we get the
twenty thirty and forty percent
unemployment without the holy economy
crashing without everybody going out
there killing people and overthrowing
the government's and going on strikes
and I don't know what else are you gonna
create robots in that environment is
that what we're gonna be doing is every
person on earth gonna have his own robot
slave doing stuff for him are these
people crazy or what and they got their
feet on the ground anymore
yeah these people are completely out of
reality anyone who thinks like that
they're thinking of this what does that
get it here give me a second I'll put it
up there it's the famous Jetsons Society
you know you got the cars running around
okay and flying through the air and you
know you have all these robots serving
you you press the buttons and everything
gets done in the house beautiful world
right and you have Rosie there she does
all the food and the dusting and surgery
a cup of coffee or whatever and
scratches your back even takes care of
the kids
yeah beautiful world this is what I
thought was so realistic that there was
still a family I mean these people
kidding me we're not getting married
the only people getting married are
homosexuals because they want to keep
the tradition and because they want to
make a point but nor you know the rest
of the world is is not getting married
we're getting divorced viewer were
becoming singles were becoming solitary
individuals in the big metropolis so you
know the families are here that that was
surrealistic in my opinion from
hanna-barbera who created the the
cartoon you know because cannot imagine
family in the future it's there is no
family the family has drawn from clams
to pectoral type societies to the
nuclear family mom and pop and a few
kids and today we even don't have that
anymore you know it's dying that's why
we're not having kids anymore
and you can't have kids anyways in the
city in an apartment so that's where
we're not having kids that's the big
picture and if you look at that big
picture all this nonsense you know
that the jetsons society that people
dream out there you know that they
simply don't have their feet planted on
the ground it's a nice to imagine and
fantasize but come back to reality
please
anyways here's another issue that I've
brought up and that was that you know
can trade save you from death and I had
these questions can technology compel
women to have children I can
consciousness make you avoid death you
know or growing old or whatever can and
you know this person tried to this
individual try to address these
questions and he did a lousy job because
he didn't understand the questions and
here's the first one you know this is
the issue of trade today and I'm saying
you know can trade save you from to make
you live forever essentially that's what
I was asking he answers you know I can
trade medicine for forward weapons for
it he can trade for anything it's the
food that keeps you alive not the trade
that keeps you alive and again I'm
talking about biology I'm talking about
your personal I mean if if you trade
will you live forever that's the
question
biologically will you leave for me live
forever
simply because you trade and the same
goes for some of these other issues that
you know I was bringing up there see
forgiveness thing up there this one was
a second issue was the technology will
technology compel city women to have 110
children like in the old days I mean
living will we increase population
because of Technology I mean is this
something we can do something about with
technology or with consciousness or with
trade or whatever people want throw in
there which far as I'm concerned is
irrelevant such technology will not
compel women to have children babies
okay for at least he agrees with that
right but he says let's look at reasons
for having babies in the past the reason
for having babies is to pass on genes
and sure some serve that some survive
look after you
you get old okay that's a retirement
right and now we have taken care of all
those problems so all these reasons have
been eliminated by technology we are
cloning or are these in the beginnings
of cloning so we're going to be cloning
people right so we're going to reproduce
them in a different way
hygiene medicine ensures 99% survival of
babies the babies we don't produce right
so it doesn't matter their technology
ensures we don't need assistance as we
age right we have retirement so we don't
need the kids to do that anymore so he
say we don't need any babies anymore and
I wonder how many people out there agree
with them you know I'm sure that there
must be lots of people who think in the
same way here's the other one third one
was consciousness let me get this in
yeah we're gonna put it your this
sometimes these get stuck here yeah
consciousness help you avoid growing old
you didn't understand the question
again I'm talking about by I'm talking
about death I'm talking what do these
things have to do with extinction and so
the fact that you have consciousness or
you know versus animals supposedly don't
have consciousness even though I
discussed that the other day does that
mean you're going to live forever
because you have consciousness that's
what I'm asking what does it have to do
with death with biology with extinction
and so all these issues that I'm raising
have to do with that with extinction
with that so that's the context please
try to understand before one of us dies
okay here's the other one that I asked
them he answered that one as well
he says well I asked if Co is going into
space it's gonna prevent you from
pooping or urinating is that gonna
change anything are you still going to
be an animal even if you go to space and
says no one yes oh and he said going
into space will have prevent you from
pooping okay thank you game but as human
if we go into space we need to be in
suspended animation
I think this guy's the suspended
animation we will not be pooping or we
become cyborgs no need to poop listen
look these people believe III I think he
really believes everybody saying yeah I
really do and it's just for me it's
incredible that some people are so far
you know they get their education
watching Hollywood movies and they think
this is the future this is the only
thing they dream and think about and
these are the conclusions to which they
reach okay
and here's the last one okay no there
was another one hold it let me see if I
can get it here this one is the one I
wanted to show okay let's get this one
out of here for a second and he says the
following he says well I asked him can
the ability to change our environment
stop you from sleeping or eating I mean
those are all vital biological type
processes no and yes again he is that we
have changed our environment more than
any other animal on earth that has ever
existed but we will we still need to
sleep and eat well thank God he
recognizes that right those Indian fella
says he hasn't eaten in 40 years
yeah grabs a yeah I know how remember
you goes huh I feel the same way
sometimes like if I haven't eaten in 40
years
I says however as we evolve beyond
mother nature's rules we still we will
we still may not need to sleep and eat
so he's thinking again that were
becoming we're gonna become some kind of
cyborg
or Android or who knows why and he says
in that case we may not need to eat and
sleep or anything for me it's just
unbelievable that there's an individual
who really believes his stuff a groan I
think he's not a baby I think he's a
little older than 10 years old right but
he actually believes in all this stuff
and I'm wondering how many people out
there really believe that this is gonna
take place
so his final point is that when the
economy collapses money will not be
accepted and there will be no incentive
to produce food why will the economy
collapse bill yeah we are growing at an
exponential rate what will stop this
economic growth well again we have
economic growth we don't have an
exponential anymore we had exponential
in the 19th century not now
right now we're growing arithmetic 'le
and that's going to tie down we can't
grow forever partly because we have no
demand we're not creating demand demand
means people who are not creating people
you don't create people you don't create
future demand car company makes its
projections based on you know what it's
gonna solve next year it hopes to sell
more cars in this year more expensively
or add more profits per car and it turns
out we're not selling cars because there
are not enough people out there to buy
the cars and not enough people with
disposable income to buy the cars either
so you get to a point where you know you
don't sell cars because the population
is not increasing and if the population
where they can continue to continue to
decline to the point where you have
fewer births and more deaths because the
old people at some point have to die so
that you get into that other part of the
curve when it goes downwards assuming we
can get to that other side of the curve
right you know without dying immediately
you're gonna have less demand you're not
gonna be selling cars and because of
that you're gonna kick people out into
the streets and that's gonna be more
unemployment and etc and less disposable
income less course being bought less
cars being manufactured or needed
etcetera it's a cyclical thing it's the
opposite cycle of what happened in 19th
century where we started inventing new
stuff and they sold like hotcakes
because everybody what everybody wanted
one today we want them but we can't have
there is no disposable income no jobs
okay so we got a different situation and
people don't seem to realize that
different ages first were deterministic
they could not have been avoided and
second that because they are different
ages they have
you can't apply the history just like a
cookie cutter on that say oh yeah we've
been through crisis before we've had
depressions and recessions no no in the
future we might have a different kind of
recession impression that we've never
had before because we are in a different
social situation social and
environmental and economic situation
okay so here here's the one that really
got me this is someone else who put this
comment in there but I liked it because
essentially this is the the notion that
most people have out there okay and
especially all the narco capitalists all
the anarcho-capitalist called narco caps
free bullies you know people who believe
in free will and don't believe in
deterministic processes and he says less
food will make the prices go up up up
and someone out of self-interest will
find a way to produce something to make
some money aha
okay so this this is essentially but the
whole I mean you can put the whole thing
in in that sense right there yeah I
think he summarized that well the way
people think that's the Smithsonian
notion of you know the wealth of nations
that people pursue their own
self-interest move the world forward
okay and that's what he's saying here
essentially he's saying you know someone
will filled the niches if potatoes are a
thousand dollars a pop some will move
out there and produce potatoes and feed
the world that's his solution that he's
convinced that's the way it works it's
always worked that way right in his mind
and so that's how he thinks and so
here's the first question I'm gonna ask
okay regarding this and see if I can get
it up here where did I put it now
I don't know where these things get
stuck and it still gets stuck okay here
it is and it's can we live without trade
can we live without money it trade were
to die tomorrow right and we live with
without trade okay you might say well is
that possible in other words people
don't want to answer that question you
know what they want to do is skip that
question say you'll never happen and I'm
not asking whether it will or will not
I'm saying can we live without trade say
yes or no question answer and not not
one that says well it'll never happen so
I'm not gonna answer that question okay
keep that in mind please hold on to that
thought here's one that fella who
answers the following on that question
and that's why maybe it's important to
answer that question okay see if I can
get it here okay and he says the
following he says if everybody just does
their freakin jobs we don't need money
okay so that everybody believes that you
need money okay here's one foe doesn't
believe we need money okay do we need
money can we live without money can we
live without Trey well these people say
it'll never happen so we don't have to
answer that question so that's your
answer and I'm saying these people the
free wheelies and so on they never heard
about the planet planet long long time
ago known as Omni trade have you ever
heard of Omni trade well let me tell you
the story of Omni trade okay and now
give me a second here to set it up a
little bit okay you say I got so many of
these I'm gonna get them close so give
me a minute here
just a minute see if we can get them all
into a proper sequence here the way at
the bottom so where is it there's
another one and one more okay let's see
if I can tell you the story of the what
happened to the planet known as Omni
trade okay
and it goes something like this
the land land far far away a long long
ago known as Omni trade there were two
great land masses separated by an ocean
deimata Nostrum bang and that's what the
planet looked like okay and the western
region had a population of about a
hundred million inhabitants and was
solely dedicated to agriculture the
eastern region had a population of ten
billion other times as much their
business activity consisted solely of
manufacturing and commerce okay the
entrepreneurs of the East would trade
goods and services with amongst
themselves right and their economies
thrive because they all believed in free
will and self-interest right and they
had renounced violence a century earlier
saying we're not animals
we are Omni traders freewill
anarcho-capitalists so they got rid of
their governments and began to do the
individual thing entrepreneurship okay
and well they traded across the border
okay
they had their river boats really uh
they had these urges and ships that
would carry goods from east to west and
west to east the Easterners would
exchange goods and services with the
Westerners which were mostly their
parents and grandparents all the
entrepreneurs who had bought the rich
Western agricultural lands and settled
there when you retired if you were
successful you went west okay the ships
and the barges would cross the modern
Ostrom back and forth bringing necessary
goods to both sides but then one day a
big catastrophe took place an act of God
and this is what happened an enormous
volcano erupted in the middle of the
modern Ostrom Mountains appeared that
reached all the way to the sky they
separated East from West the two
continents was physically separated the
Easterners had
it's the trade but were isolated from
their source of food okay so you see
what happened here they had an
interruption guy of their flow of food
and so what happened was you know the
Easterners had much to trade but were
isolated from their source of food the
Western Region they couldn't grow food
fast enough to satisfy demand locally
the entire east side was mostly asphalt
and concrete it would take months to
grow food again even if they applied
their best efforts and technology to the
problem the 10 million eastern Omni
traders quickly discovered that they
were still animals they needed food to
stay alive and food with what they
didn't have even if they traded their
most prized possessions many starve to
death others quickly rediscovered their
animal instincts and reverted to their
old natural ways they became scavengers
and predators and cannibals in the
asphalt jungle until no one was left and
those on the western side the old folk
they just lived out what remained of
their days they were too old to
reproduce and they ain't generation of
their own kind little bedtime story yeah
people can't believe that they can be
isolated from food they say trade trade
trade trade but even in these days you
know there's a distance between the
source of food where it's produced and
where it's delivered and you know that
might be a problem people think that
they're always going to have food upon
the table but for sure if you don't have
food you die so food is something to be
taken seriously for anyone considering
an extinction theory and it turns out
nobody even bothers thinking about it
because then you'd say it's never gonna
happen
but look why is it is food gonna
disappear well here I gave you a
scenario where food can disappear it
doesn't disappear
you're just isolated from it for some
reason from the physical physical
geographical reason you get separated
from it can that happen
well again it's food for thought for
people to think you don't have to agree
with me I'm saying our economy is going
to collapse global economy the man's
artificial economy as I call it is gonna
collapse we can't grow forever
partly because demand doesn't grow
forever party because population doesn't
grow forever and when population levels
off demand levels off
you have lusty men and companies begin
to merge which is what you're seeing out
there they kick out employees because
they have these economies of scale and
those people have to find jobs in the
service industry which is about all
that's left and services don't produce
wealth things I showed you the other day
the idea well here you can see it in the
picture between the east and west let's
see if I can find it here I think it's
this one and you'll see that the east
side is all got skyscrapers and on the
west side all you have is farming land
ok so you know we have the situation
more or less here on earth this this is
the situation on earth we have two
regions just about everywhere now will
it will that stay forever well I don't
know all I'm saying is as population
declines we're gonna have less to sell
or less turbine there's going to be less
demand because of that companies will
close their doors pick more people out
into the streets they become unemployed
they do services and services is not
wealth the way you can see it there in
that picture is that you know if you
have this bird's-eye view and you look
at a farm land you compare it against
the city you can tell which one is
wealthier which one has more
construction you don't see services in
either place all you see is what's there
what the
physical structures and in one case you
see food and the other one you see
buildings and it's really hard to get
people in these days who are born in
this world to even understand what I'm
talking about because they think yeah oh
yeah that's I know what's out there
well do you I mean do you understand the
consequences of what's out there of what
would happen if suddenly you know food
starts running out where you gonna get
your food are you gonna go to the local
supermarket where are they going to get
their food well someone's gonna fill in
the blank you know fill in the niche
that's what the capitalist narco caps
are saying and the problem with that is
again that's only as long as you have
money as long as people believe in money
and at some point the economy is going
to collapse government's debts it's
gonna go out the room through the roof
money is going to be worthless be and
money is only used to pay salaries
essentially and it's those salaries that
keep the economy going by buying things
that go back to production and cetera
it's a circle it's a clothing circle and
all you have to do is interrupt that
circle somehow meaning that you devalue
money so much and you can so many people
out into the unemployment line that
pretty much you have the few workers
maintaining the many does unemployed
that's one situation and then the other
thing is we there was a time for over
90% of human history if we talk about
humans believe living now for 200,000
years since the species was created
that's the overall feeling out there the
number that's given 200,000 years that
our species has been around we had no
trade there was no trade in the pally
in the upper Palaeolithic but some
people you know you get some
paleontologists saying oh yeah they
trade it see so you know for here you
had the Neanderthal prostitute and you
know swinging her purse you know and
collecting seashells I mean you know I
don't know what these people have in
their minds now there was no trade in
the
Palaeolithic we invented trade former
commerce in the neolithic and so just
like we invented trade hey we can
destroy it just as well because it's a
creation that it's a human creation and
people say well that we do it for
self-interest individuals have
self-interest but corporations they have
self-interest off obviously as well as
well as government but you know an
individual might be willing to produce
food for himself corporations don't
produce food for themselves they produce
food for others only because of money
that's the self-interest the
self-interest is not the food to feed
you to make you healthy or or be alive
no it's uh the the reason they produce
food is to make money to make profits so
it's a different self-interest to keep
yourself alive than to make profits for
the investors anyways that's my take on
that and I wish all of you a happy new
year
that's in a few days and we get into
2020 how long are we gonna last are we
gonna last to 2030
well that's food for thought that's for
you to think and yes please factor in
that you may run out of food and if you
run out of food what are you gonna do
about it
you're gonna grow potatoes starting
today and wait three months for them to
grow are you gonna defend that that
garden against all predators that come
near you your neighbors wanting to share
in your bounty so keep all that in mind
we'll see you on what is it on Sunday
and if I don't see you on Sunday which I
think I will happy new year we'll see
you there
bye-bye